Russia has suffered a number of setbacks
in its war against Ukraine one of the
most glaring its recent big call-up of
more troops a plan which does not appear
to be working Holly Williams is in
Ukraine's capital of Kiev with the
latest
good morning Russia's announced that its
finished mobilizing 300 000 reservists
to back up its forces here in Ukraine
but there are more and more signs that
Russia's Invasion could be unraveling
Russia's mobilization has caused anger
at home forcing the old and
inexperienced inter-uniform with claims
they're short of even basic equipment
the call up followed weeks of
embarrassing setbacks for Russian forces
as Ukraine has retaken swaths of its
territory
on Russian State TV at times the tone
seems close to despair
Russia miscalculated its strength and
for eight straight months can't win says
this commentator
and perhaps another sign of Russian
desperation is its new tactic targeting
the Ukrainian power grid it's led to
blackouts here in Ukraine but no
collapse in morale
as Russia's nuclear forces started
annual drills this week President Putin
repeated his government's allegation
that Ukraine could detonate a
radioactive device a so-called dirty
bomb
some fear Russia's planning a false flag
operation staging an incident and
blaming Ukraine perhaps as a pretext for
using a nuclear weapon
I'm Mark
guaranteeing you that it's a false flag
operation yet don't know
but it would be a serious serious
mistake Ukraine's defense minister told
us Russia's exhausted and trying to
force Ukraine and the West to negotiate
but what you're describing is sort of
nuclear or radioactive blackmail yes
this is a black male
in a bizarre speech this week President
Putin railed against the West including
gay pride parades and so-called cancel
culture but he also said that it would
make no sense for Russia to use a
nuclear weapon President Biden's
response to that was quote if he has no
intention why does he keep on talking
about it Michelle
all right Holly thank you